so
one of the things that um we we do is um
is
is we it's creating a culture in which
people understand that the reason we're
giving feedback is not to quote unquote
criticize them but to help them grow as
human beings um and that has to be a
that has to be established like this
this is what we're gonna the advice i i
offer is it's not just a checklist that
you do and everything goes fine you know
you create a culture in which
uh difficult conversations and uh and
and critical feedback are welcomed or at
least understood um but it's also how we
give it um usually we give it by pulling
out a piece of paper and pointing out
the thing that's wrong
um and you know and saying you've got to
fix something right we usually point to
the evidence first
um as opposed to starting by with by by
the human being which is you know
there's stuff i want to share with you i
don't know where what it means but i
wanted to raise it with you in case
there is an issue
um because i care about you and i want
to see that you grow here but there's
some evidence that things are going a
little sideways and i want to i want to
address them with them to see what
opportunities there are or if there's
anything wrong because i don't know the
reasons behind it but um here's
for example um the way you talked to
your teammates the other day was a
little harsh and ordinarily i'd be one
say oh you know you're having a bad day
it's no problem you know everybody gets
uh everybody gets a bad day but you've
been really beating up on people
um i don't even know if you're aware of
that
right um
and sometimes they say i'm having a hard
time and it opens up or they'll say i
wasn't even aware i didn't even know or
it reveals something as opposed to
saying stop yelling at people nobody
wants to work for you if all you do is
yell at people you know it's hard for
people to receive and so good feedback
is not just about conveying the point
we're trying to make it's about creating
a condition in which the person is more
likely to listen and hear it
so we're all proud of ourselves once
we've told them we did you did you give
her the feedback yeah i told her right
did they hear the feedback
uh different question